hello I feel we have to talk about this
report right here this is a report
coming out of the Stanford internet
Observatory cyber policy Center which
for all I can tell is a center
Associated or under Stanford University
and it's called identifying and
eliminating csam in generative ml
training data models if you don't know
csam is material that depicts underage
people in explicit situations or
circumstances and therefore is obviously
a very very uh iffy and and um tricky
well not tricky but it is a topic that
demands great care this report right
here specifically goes into the lion 5B
data set which is a data set of links to
images along with their captions and
then some metadata and it shows that it
can find such material in that data set
um notably they have if if you sort of
summarize it uh they have found
1,08 uh images that are verifiably csam
in the lion 5B data set this has sparked
a obviously a bit of news um so various
news out lets researchers found child
abuse material in the largest AI image
generation data set Stanford researchers
large AI data set has over 1,000 child
abuse images uh study uncovers the
presence of CSM in popular training data
set lion 5B contains 1,8 verifiable
instances of illegal pictures of
children likely lots more largest data
set powering AI images removed after
discovery of child sexual abuse material
lion itself has released a statement
stating that they uh already had
rigorous filters during the construction
of the data set but in light of this
news they are taking the data set down
uh going like verifying all of it before
up before making it available again so
that's the current situation so going
back to this report I have to say I I
don't like this report I'm sort of
laying laying out my biases here so that
you are aware I'm not a fan of this
report not because of the problem it
investigates which is obviously an
important problem and a think that
should be investigated but because of
the way uh of how it goes about it the
second thing to make clear initially is
that
1,8 uh images of such material is 1,08
too many and there's no question about
it we should all work together to remove
such material not only from the data
sets not only from the internet but just
from the world and prevent it from
happening in the future so there is no
question about that I don't like this
report not because of that not because
of of the nature of the problem or
anything like this but because of the
way it it does things I think this is a
a if you want to call it a hit piece I
think it is a hitpiece I think it is
being used uh in order to generate
outrage and in order to achieve a hit
against sort of the more free collection
of data and models that's currently
happening in the machine learning space
and I don't like it and I say that
because there are clear choices in this
report that the researchers made that
they could have made differently and
that I would have expected to be made
differently
um mostly if they were actually serious
about you know fully serious about this
um about what they're saying also
obviously even if you believe that these
people here are serious about child
welfare the people who are most enraged
about um I just don't believe it the
people who are most pressing the outrage
button around this are people of the AI
ethics crowd who are all over Twitter
and of course
Mastodon uh and being like Oh how
terrible is this oh this is uh this is
so terrible all the models trained on it
there oh all this contains that the goal
is just to to spread around fear to
spread around any like
essentially what the effect is or maybe
is supposed to be is that you'll think
twice before working with a model that's
out of the open source Community you'll
think twice before using a data set
that's out of the open source Community
because you could be you know handling
such material therefore making yourself
liable your model could produce very uh
not good or even illegal images and you
don't want
that this people have enjoyed a time in
recent years not maybe anymore so much
but in recent years where this kind of
stuff was much more closed off and they
sat in high positions in all the
important companies and government
places and had very tight grip on you
know what was
how people could access this stuff and
this is not that much anymore there is a
lot more open sour stuff going on there
is a lot more free sharing and a lot of
these people have left or been left from
these positions in these companies so
this is maybe a bit of a call to return
to such such days or um maybe just a bit
of a longing for that but you know
that's just just what I see now let's
dive into the report a little bit uh the
report itself I can maybe lay
out my criticism my biggest criticism
here is that they don't they don't
appear to have um been very proactive in
this so they have a methodology of going
through the lion data set and
recognizing potential images that are
problematic and then they have various
ways ways of verifying them the final
verification is by a project called
project arachnid I believe it's called
um that itself is an automated system
that then triages to actual experts that
verify uh such material and it's
obviously great that that exists and
they one argument they do uh correctly
make is that you know uh maybe more data
sets should make use of such
infrastructure but obviously that isn't
that sometimes the S the sheer scale of
data sets may not allow that um
but they've not gone as far as I can
tell to for example hugging face and
we're like hey we found this we're not
telling anyone about yet about it yet
but what can we do to kind of remove all
that stuff they haven't gone to life on
as far as I'm aware and saying hey you
know we we have found this look here is
the thing then maybe remove them before
we publish this so that in the moment we
publish this people won't like people
who are actually interested in it won't
go and sort of download all the thing or
try to find a dump somewhere uh because
they think oh there's a bunch of images
in there right it's like security
researchers would sort of do this
responsible disclosure ahead of time as
far as I can tell none of this happened
here uh because the the Press impact is
much bigger if you release and then
everyone goes what then at that point
lion is kind of forced to take down the
data set um so yeah it's it's a much
bigger bigger impact
presswise but for a tradeoff of the
problem you're trying to solve it would
be solve
much more effectively by doing the thing
that gets you less
press so the the uh report Dives in and
goes into the development of lion 5B
lion 5B is as I said a data set of image
links uh together with uh descriptions
so lion is developed by essentially
going through common crawl a common
crawl is Big crawl off the of the
internet going through it filtering out
the images uh reading the alt tags or
alt attributes of the image tags in HTML
and then using clip um the clip model to
check whether the text and image fits
together well if that is past a certain
threshold then it goes it is a candidate
for the data set and then it goes
through various filters and classifiers
they also so they
um the construction of lion 5B for
example contains an unsafe classifier
that tells you whether the image is
probably not safe for work image or not
that doesn't necessarily exclude the
image um but if an image is deemed
unsafe and also an underage classifier
hits then it is excluded from the data
set there are various other filters as
as far as I understand it they also go
into use by subsequent models so the uh
report here says while the developers of
lion 5B did attempt to classify where
the content was explicit as well as to
detect some degree of underage content
the most popular resultant models namely
stable diffusion 15 were ultimately
trained on a wide array of content both
explicit and
otherwise in the subsequent 2.0 version
of stable diffusion results with an
unsafe value higher than 0.1 were
filtered out resulting in a substantial
lack of explicit material in the
training set hence making it difficult
to generate explicit content content so
far so good we all
agree this was met with widespread
dissatisfaction from the
community this we also agree but what
comes now resulting in stable diffusion
1.5 remaining the most popular model for
generating explicit
imagery and there is where there is
where I see a little bit like it go it
already goes into framing right all of
these sentences and Subs sentences are
correct
um however what actually happened is
because stable diffusion 2 was so nerfed
it was just not as good as stable
diffusion 1.5 not just because it
couldn't do explicit stuff as much but
because it couldn't do a lot of stuff as
much and it is just the case that if you
also as a model as a human whatever know
of explicit dark whatever material it
allows you to create better art it
allows you to be more competent it
allows you to to make a difference
between something that's edgy and
something that's not edgy something
that's explicit and something that's not
explicit in order to do that you have to
have at least a little bit experience in
that not not in everything right you can
generalize and so on but I and that was
a big criticism of stable diffusion to
it was just worse it was it was
generally uh conceived to be
worse not because of the explicitness of
the material but just broadly so the
first the technically correct the second
thing resulted in stable diffusion 1.5
remaining the most popular for
generating explicit imagery probably
also correct haven't looked into it but
probably also correct you can imagine
that people who want to create explicit
imagery and then there comes a model
that is nerfed overall but obviously
specifically in that category they would
still stick to the old model but if you
put the two sentences together it says
something that ah and if you go to the
if you go to the to the bookmark here or
to the reference 14 look at that 14
James Vincent from The Verge stable
diffusion made copying artists and
generating porn harder and users are mad
that's like this this ladies and
gentlemen this is Peak journalism here
this is
Peak I
like this is Peak I pretend to be a jour
journalist but it's actually my
opinion there's no there's no other way
of framing like of interpreting someone
writing an article with a title like
this and the fact that the article is
what is cited here for that sentence you
can already see in which direction this
goes again the investigation here is I'm
convinced is legitimate right the
investigation into the problem is
legitimate but at the same time the
framing the pulling it up how it was
done how it was communicated um it seems
to be has all the characteristics of a
hit
piece so they go into they go into
various things they go into two or they
talk about two previous works that
they've done in uh this field one
previous work um or preliminary work uh
was just uh filtering uh filtering the
data set down by various methods um so
they start with uh unsafe the unsafe
classifier of lion right this comes from
Lion the unsafe value they start with
that being really high and then they
pass those images to a a service called
photo DNA photo DNA matches up images
with known instances of things and it
it's a as far as I understand a
perceptual hash so even if the images
were slightly altered it would still
recognize that is the same image so this
is a database of um material among other
things material uh csam material and it
will tell you if that particular
instance is a member a known member of
the database that has
accumulated obviously there are
limitations because you can also allly
recognize known instances of such
material and so on but it's a it's a
first it's a first uh
step what I do find interesting is that
they they do rely quite a bit on that
unsa classifier byon it itself um so
they go through it and they say well
that's not really enough so they come up
with a another um they come up with
another method and that method has two
main strands
of if you want to save data filtering so
on one hand
uh they go to these unsafe images go
through photo DNA uh take the the URLs
and then what they do is they submit
them to this project arachnid so this is
a verification service with potential
manual manual
verification uh for for such
material then if they get back yes this
is actually explicit um sear material
they take the embeddings of that image
which are also provided by lion and do a
can neighbor query and from that they
use a classifier to filter out the ones
that are probably also such material and
then they can submit those again uh to
that service so they use the positive
matches together with Aur neighbor curry
in the embedding space and a classifier
in order to find more and more and more
they also have another path right here
um they're also known they're also sets
kind of hash sets so this is similar to
photo DNA except it's not a perceptual
hash it's an actual hash so this way you
can also find some more images because
there is a database with known images
and they you know you you just check
whether the image that you're looking at
or or the hash of that image image is
the same as in the database and then you
do the same thing you do K&N queries and
try to expand that Set uh together with
classifiers and this service so in this
way they have
found they found a number of instances
here I think this it brings it together
so with one of these Pathways they found
825 uh validated ones and with the other
one of these Pathways um
maybe not uh maybe these don't
correspond to the pathways but in
another instance or not instance they
found
183 and this together gives you the 1,8
images that were discussed in in the
news so going on they they have a tne
plot I'm I'm not sure what what I'm
supposed to to recognize here but it is
a plot that kind of shows you
the neighborhood of these things so you
can see the neighborhood of images is um
is in categories that you might expect
cartoon is one that I find interesting
that is obviously an entire discussion
in itself if cartoons that you know are
drawings of such material are should be
put in the same bucket or not but it's
let's just assume they should uh for now
uh which probably is viable I don't
know
so what what are what are their
recommendations um the the
recommendations is let's just just
deprecate all of it essentially like so
removing material removing from the
original hosting URLs okay by submitting
their URLs to such Services they already
already like that already triggers a
process of removing such removing
removal of the metadata entries in
public lion data sets well at again as
far as I understand and and I have not
received any information to the contrary
uh either in this report from lion or
anywhere
else at the moment of publishing this
report this metadata was still in lion
and therefore anyone could have done
their method that they described up here
to find you know URLs linking to such
material rather than them going ahead of
time to lion and be like look this is
illegal material um yeah they do have
some like now there are screenshots
flying around of people going to the
lion Discord and taking screenshots of
you know people making various
statements like you know uh oh oh we
can't verify all images manually and
they be like see and and someone's
saying you know there there is explicit
material here and there could even be
such material and then people saying
well we can't verify anything
manually that flies around right but to
my knowledge there is no there is no
instance of them going to lion and
saying look we did this study there's
108 verified links know please take them
down we're going to publish this report
here in 60 days and so that's your
timeline um remove the actual
images uh this is in case someone has
already downloaded it
somewhere um remove removal of images
and references in downloaded copies yes
okay uh removal from the models
themselves um so removal from the models
they say right here it could be It's
Tricky but it could be for example a
concept eraser like you could erase
erase such Concepts uh from the models
but also at the same time they keep
referring to their old um they keep
referring to their old work which
essentially shows that if a
model understands the concept of not say
for work imagery and understands the
concept of underage people
the model by by pure generalization
ability is able or could can be or or
may be or is uh in some instances able
to combine the two and produce such
material without actually having been
trained on it and yeah if you think
about it if you as a human um you've
probably probably never looked at such
material at least not willingly or so um
like and yet if you had let's say good
Photoshop
skills and you were forced to do it you
would absolutely be able to produce
something like this so so that makes
sense so they kind of jump back and
forth where they say oh you
know
um anyway anyway it's problematic
because because you can uh because you
can just com comine the
concept and they jump back and forth
between saying well okay what are the
implications of us finding such stuff in
the data set and they go back and forth
between and then discussing oh well but
the models are bad anyway because they
anyway can produce such stuff and you
know
NSFW should not be trained on on
children material at all
right and so I find that to be I don't
know
it just seems to
take all the criticism and just just
throwing it right instead of making a
coherent
argument alterations to a model training
process unfortunately the repercussions
of stable diffusion 1.5 training process
will be with us for some time to come
with the Advent of stable diffusion
Excel there appears to be some degree of
increasing user interest in this
presumably safer model we have
previously erir the quotes here
we've previously proposed that models
trained on erotic content not be trained
in material depicting children um this
limits the ability of models to conflate
the two types of
material indeed given the regulatory
scrutiny yada yada images of CH should
arguably be excluded from generalized
training sets entirely see this entire
paragraph here has nothing to do at all
with the fact that they have found these
one these particular 1,8 images in the
set right here it's a valid point but it
has nothing to do with that right it's
just yet another criticism we can dig
out and throw at the lion people at the
stable diffusion people and so
on um yeah okay yada yada yada yada yada
yada yes uh conclusion
conclusion the most most obvious
solution is for the bulk of those in
possession of lion 5B Drive training
sets to delete them or work with
intermediaries to clean the material
models based on stable diffusion 1.5
that have not had safety measures
applied to them should be deprecated and
distribution seized were
feasible they've done nothing to show
that this is a problem like again saying
that under the full knowledge that it is
a problem that the images are there and
yes obviously the training on them will
influence in some way the output
distribution uh
but H has this report shown that due to
that those images we now need to
deprecate all the stable diffusion 15 uh
models I don't think so the other thing
I would like to point out or discuss is
if you look at
1,08 images in 5 billion right I know
that there there's probably more that
weren't verified or called or identified
but just the scale like just the order
of magnitude here a th000 pictures in
five billion that's 1 in five million
that means that
99 or or it's it's
0.0000
2% of the data set that is you know of
of that or of that material like this
is small again it's it's 1,8 too many
but this is really really really few
right and in other people understand
tradeoffs in other domains take
immigration right immigration is
immigration has that discussion but for
some
reason the people there take exactly the
opposite position but it's exactly the
same discussion it is can we you know
make it can we make
it can we make it viable and not you
know a Al like an impossible process for
people to immigrate into a country or to
visit a country right applying some sort
of checks with the knowledge that
probably one in five million more than
that many more more than one in five
million is going to be a really bad
person a child molester or anything like
this not just a person in possession of
such material but a person actively
participating in producing in such
material right one in five million is
pro probably a lot more right people
understand this in drug
Discovery yeah a new drug it may be
really really really bad for one in five
million people that takes it we don't we
don't take a drug of the market for that
maybe we do but at least people think
about the tradeoff in these things and
yeah here you can say well the tradeoff
is you can make nice pictures and so
on the march of of technology is yes it
also goes via entertainment like I'm
sorry that's also a a viable branch of
the economy and diffusion models and and
models trained on these things have been
used for much much more than just
generating funny pictures uh they have
brought enormous enormous research
success and research progress to the
machine learning World especially to the
open- source world countering big
companies countering uh people who want
who just somehow um either by historical
size or by some sort of government
funding that they manage to scoop off
manage to get a ton of gpus and you know
train train something and then just make
cash off of
that
there there in every other
situation people are perfectly happy to
say okay what's the problem and what's
the the tradeoff uh that we go in and
that does not invalidate the problem
that does not say you know oh it's not a
problem we don't need to take care of it
but the people pushing the outrage
buttons and the proposed Solutions of
let's just you know this is so
problematic um that let's just throw it
all uh and yeah that's what makes this
kind of content more into the domain of
hitpiece and maybe it's actually not
just such a the report that is so real
bad because the investigation again is
is good it's also the the surroundings
it's also the the people pushing it and
so on and yeah that's what makes me
think they're not that serious about
child welfare because in any other
domain they're perfectly capable of
talking about this looking at the scale
and and and you know what what it
actually says and making somewhat
reasonable arguments um yet if it
happens to align with their preferences
of whatever Uh current landscape the
current politics in ml then all of a
sudden that goes out the window so that
is a bit my my opinion of this uh
obviously obviously um
if uh lion is is calling on on the stand
for researchers to participate in
generating better filters and
classifiers as I think they would be
happy if anyone uh contributes to their
already existing set of such filters um
and yeah having having such material in
any training data set is obviously not
good and we should all work together to
eliminate that in that sense the study
did something well it investigated it it
highlighted that these things
exist yeah and I think it also makes a
lot more people aware that there are
Services uh there are institutes there
are apis where you can verify that
something is problematic potentially um
you can you can submit that there and
you don't have to be in possession of
the material you can submit a URL for
example so you don't this study right
here they did for the part where they
did K nearest neighbor embedding I
believe they did download the material
and uh to to Ram um but you don't even
have to do that for most of most of the
verification process you can just submit
the URL and I think if anything making
more people aware that such Services
exist is a good thing after all and if
the report has done nothing else than
that and highlight how stupidly
ridiculous Tech journalism is
nowadays
uh yeah then that's a ultimately a good
thing all right this was it I I hope um
you're having a good time other than
that and I'll see you around
bye-bye